Hey guys,
Today is a special day because I just want to sit
here and talk with you guys and do a Bible study.
Now today, we're going to talk about what it
means to grow spiritually stronger
in God, as a man, and how to do it.
And it's special because I'm
gonna do the Bible study with you.
And it's part of my new book called
Bold Pursuit, a 90-day devotional
for men seeking the heart of God.
And I want to work through Day 14
which is about capable and equipped.
Now, I'm going to read here from the
e-book and yes it is available as an e-book so
if you live in a country where you cannot get
the physical book - the hard copy - then you can
get it online as an e-book or if you drive far
distances you can get the Audible version as well.
I've done a whole voice over just for you guys.
Now, let's get into this.
Day 14 - Capable and Equipped.
All scripture - not just some of it -
all scripture - is inspired by God and
beneficial for teaching.
Listen carefully.
For rebuke - for correction - for
training in righteousness - so that
the man or woman of God may be fully
capable, equipped for every good work.
It doesn't say half capable - it says
fully capable - which means the Bible
gives us everything that we need to be
able to live as Godly men and Godly women.
It is the word of God which He
already chose to reveal to us.
The Logos and that's in 2 Timothy 3:16 to 17.
Now, we live in an amazing time.
We can access vast amounts of information with
just a few keystrokes and even now with AI,
times are changing so fast.
Yet, that creates unrealistic
expectations for most of us, especially when
it comes to life's most pressing questions.
Why did God let this happen?
Why doesn't He answer my prayer?
What's His plan for my life?
We get frustrated and discouraged
when we don't receive immediate answers.
Now, I'm not preaching to you guys because
sometimes I'm guilty of this as well. Because
I don't follow God's will, I want to follow my
own will and I want things to get done.
I want God to answer my prayers and I
want it done my way.
And that's not right.
We should follow God's way all the time.
We should follow the example of Jesus
when He prayed.
Not my will be done, but yours be done.
And Jesus said if you want to follow
me, then you need to deny yourself.
Pick up your cross and follow Jesus.
If you don't do that,
then you cannot follow Christ.
You cannot be a disciple and I
say here we get frustrated and discouraged when
we don't receive immediate answers and that is
because we're acting in the flesh.
We want immediate answers.
We want our will instead
of focusing on God's will.
But look at 2 Timothy 3:16 to 17 which
describes the process of spiritual maturity.
Teaching - rebuke - correction and training
- these things require time and effort.
It's not things that will happen immediately.
It requires time and effort.
They call for patience and diligence.
And they show us important
truths about God and His Word.
First, God wants us to rely on Him,
not on ourselves.
On Him.
When Moses led the people of
Israel to the promised land,
God provided just enough manna every
morning to sustain them for that day.
God wants us as His people to
come to Him daily for our needs.
He breathed out scripture because He
wants us to turn to His word every day
for guidance and wisdom.
This is so important.
We live in a day and age where a lot
of people move away from God's word
and listen to preachers who preach to
itching ears - to false preachers - and
they don't know God's Word.
When I ask a lot of
Christians - do you know the Bible?
Have you read it at least once?
They say no, even though they've
been Christians for years.
But Jesus says that if you love
me, you obey my commandments.
But how can you do that if
you don't know His word?
You can't.
You see, if you
want to become spiritually stronger you need to
go to the cross first and then to God's Word.
[
Hebrews 4:12]
This is where you get the difference between
your soul life - your fleshly
nature - and the spiritual nature,
where you can become stronger by reading His word.
To read it, write it on your heart and to live it.
Not just to be hearers of
the Word, but to be doers.
Second - the harder we search for something,
the more valuable it becomes to us.
Proverbs 2 compares the wisdom
of God's Word to a treasure.
Like all good treasures,
it's not easily discovered.
We must commit to searching the scriptures daily.
That's like the good Bereans, right?
Who searched the scriptures daily
to see if these things were so.
We have to dig - sift - and dig some more.
The harder we work to discover God's wisdom,
the more we appreciate it.
When we find.
You know, my dad was a wonderful man.
I was blessed by God to give me my
dad because he was a preacher.
But he lived the way he preached.
And all the sermons I heard from him -
the Bible studies together as a family -
all the things I learned from him -
they were like seeds put in my heart.
And now when I'm older I start to understand it.
Because it starts to to grow into plants.
Into a beautiful garden.
And this is so true.
The harder we work to discover God's wisdom,
the more we appreciate it when we find it.
So now I start to understand things
that I couldn't understand before,
because I wasn't spiritually there yet.
But now a lot of the things that my dad
said - because he was a spiritual
man - a mature Christian - he
understood a lot of things that I don't.
But now I'm starting to understand more and
more and it becomes more special to me now.
I appreciate it a lot more.
Third - spiritual maturity
is rarely what we imagine.
Our quest for God's wisdom is
often tied to a specific situation.
We want to know how to deal with a pressing
problem or receive guidance in making a decision.
Now, listen carefully.
But God has something much bigger in mind.
His ways are not our ways.
He wants to make us capable and equipped for
every good work, not just for this thing that
you have to take care of.
For every good work,
so He gives us more than we ask for.
Because He knows what we need.
He shows us perspectives we
could never see on our own.
In 2 Corinthians 12: 7 to 8,
Paul said he prayed three times for God
to take away the thorn in his flesh.
Paul likely believed he could be a more effective
Christian minister without his affliction
but God helped him see that his physical weakness
actually made him a more effective minister.
This is amazing because it shows us that
what we think is best for us is usually
not what's best for us.
God, who is perfect.
We are not perfect.
God who is perfect, who's not even
controlled by time, space, or matter.
He lives outside of it.
Because He created it.
He can see the future.
He knows what's best for you.
He knows exactly what we need.
All we need to do is to fully trust
Him - not in ourselves - but in God.
Knowing - trusting - that He
knows what is best for us.
Fourth - God's timing is perfect.
This is something that you
will always need to remember.
He reveals His truths when we need them, and
when we are ready to understand and apply them.
This is so important.
We may read a certain Bible
passage the same way 10 times in a row.
But as time passes, we grow in our faith.
When we are ready, God may reveal
a piece of truth in the passage
that we have never noticed before.
That's how we grow.
I talked about this just a little bit earlier on.
The example that I use with my dad.
Certain things that he talked about -
scripture - that I didn't understand but
now as I'm slowly maturing into a mature
Christian, I'm starting to understand it.
And let me tell you there's still
so much more that I don't know.
You know, walking on this road of
sanctification with God is like a gold mine.
You know, you just see there's a gold mine.
And you're here at the beginning, and you start to
see the gold - but then when you look inside, you
see, man, there are tunnels leading everywhere.
And there's not just gold - there's diamonds.
So oh man, it just doesn't stop.
And that is it.
You will never stop to grow spiritually,
but while you are on this road of sanctification
you need to understand that God's timing is
perfect and that you cannot force God to do
certain things when you are not ready for it yet.
Let's continue.
We plant the seeds by spending
time in prayer and in God's word.
But ultimately, God determines our right
of spiritual maturity when we abide in Him.
John 15 verse 4, right?
Abide in me - without me you can do nothing.
You know, the older I get the
more precious this becomes to me.
Jesus, you know you can take the whole
world, but just keep giving me Jesus.
That's all I need.
I just want to abide in Him,
know him more deeper, fuller.
Jesus.
Always - only - Jesus.
Everything else this world - the things
of this world - it will pass away.
All that matters is your relationship with Jesus.
And I can't wait for that day
when I will stand in front of Him.
Seeing His face, talking to Him, oh man.
I can talk about this the
whole day, but let's continue.
Now, this is the Bible study of Day 14.
We just finished it.
But at the end of every Bible study day,
I asked people to dig deep.
This is where you examine yourself,
where you look in the mirror.
And where you are brutally honest with yourself.
There's two questions that
you need to ask yourself here.
As we grow in spiritual maturity,
we become more dependent on God.
Ask yourself the following questions
and answer them truthfully.
One - do you change the Bible
to fit in with your lifestyle?
Or do you change your life
to fit in with the Bible?
This is so important.
Because remember Jesus calls us to deny
ourselves, to pick up our cross and follow Him.
That means we put Him first in everything.
We don't put ourselves first - the way we
want to live this short temporary world.
In this world - in this life - and now you all
know about the chaos that's going on out there
in the world.
Where
people say my truth is my truth
- your truth is your truth.
Truth is hard to find.
They don't even know how to define
a man or how to define a woman anymore.
They want to change everything.
And it's more important than ever to stick
to God's Word, to go back to the Bible.
And I want to say this to a lot of you
who are in churches and in ministries
who are focusing on what
is happening in the world.
What is now - in - what is modern
- plans - things to figure out
systems - to work to to get more people in
the church and maybe you at home as well.
I need to try the the 10 steps to
do this or the 20 steps to do this.
No you don't.
All you need to do is go back to God's Word.
Remember at the beginning of this Bible study,
2 Timothy 3:16 says all scripture is inspired
by God and beneficial for teaching, for rebuke,
for correction, for training and righteousness,
so that the man or woman of God may be
fully capable, equipped for every good work.
God's Word is all you need.
The Logos and also together with the Rhema word
how He guides you through the Holy Spirit.
That's all you need.
So I'm asking you to ask yourself - am I
truly following God's word as it is written?
Am I changing my lifestyle according to the
Word - or - do I want to interpret or change
the Word to mean something it doesn't,
just so it will fit in with my lifestyle?
That's what a lot of people are doing today.
But that means if you change the Word, then
you are not practicing what God wants you
to practice.
You're not obeying His word.
You're creating something that
is not real in your own head.
Fake religion.
So let's go back to God's Word and follow Him.
The second question here is - how might
God make you better equipped to serve Him?
Now, I'm just thinking here.
I wonder what many of you will
answer to these two questions.
How about this?
How about you answer it and you
put it in the comment section?
Then we have a little bit of fellowship together.
Number one: Do you change the Bible to fit in
with your lifestyle or do you change
your life to fit in with the Bible?
Number two: How might God make
you better equipped to serve Him?
Add in the comment section, and then if you want
to get my book and go through all the other 90-day
devotionals, it will really help you.
I talk about a lot of things like
what it means to be a real reborn Christian.
How to worship God in spirit and in truth.
How to fight spiritual battles,
through the spirit and not the flesh.
What is the role of a husband in marriage?
How to come to the point of complete surrender.
And so much more.
Now, I just want to say it again,
to grow spiritually stronger as a man
you need to put God first in your life.
You need to study His Word.
Remember, the Word of God is
sharper than a two-edged sword, cutting
to the vision between soul and spirit.
If you want to become spiritually stronger,
you need to understand God's Word.
You need to write it on
your heart and then live it.
There's a lot of people who also know the Word
of God, but don't apply it in their lives.
You can know scripture, but if you just
quote it and say it and work with it in
the flesh, it means absolutely nothing.
You need to understand, to read the Word
through the Holy Spirit that is helping you,
revealing the truth to you, so that you can
understand it and then apply it in your life.
Now, if you want to get my new book, here it is.
Bold Pursuit.
The book is also available
as an e-book and an Audible version as well.
Now, just to make it a bit more special,
I want to read what's on the back of
the book because this is so important.
You could pursue a lot of things in
life: Money. Relationships. Power.
But only one pursuit brings satisfaction on earth.
Because only one pursuit matters for eternity.
Becoming a true man of God.
The action-orientated teachings
in Bold Pursuit will challenge and equip you to
pursue God above all else in your daily life.
I mean, what can be more important than that?
Nothing.
As you dig deep into God's Word, you'll experience
the fulfillment of making your relationship with
Jesus your greatest priority, through each day's
straightforward devotional reading packed with
powerful biblical insights.
You'll explore how to
worship God in spirit, and in truth.
What it means to engage in spiritual battle.
What sin - and isn't.
And why it matters.
Where to find hope when you're feeling hopeless.
Practical ways to overcome destructive
habits and addictions.
And, how to make Bible study
and prayer an integrated part of your life.
Each daily reading in Bold Pursuit combines a
Bible passage with a short devotional that speaks
to the real issues men face at work and home.
Prayer prompts, reflection questions,
and action items bring focus to each day.
And it was special for me to go through
one of these days together with you.
So you now know what to expect
with the other days as well.
In an age of distraction and busyness,
every man's true calling remains the same...
listen carefully ... to walk with God
who created you for great things.
And find the meaning and purpose your soul craves.
Guys, thank you so much for
doing this Bible study with me.
I love you and I'll see you in the next video.
Bye.